car là vous
portez
c'est l'heure de la relève devant la
tante du prince avant une réunion de
l'état-major dirigée par joachim murat
est bienvenu sous l'ère napoléonienne et
celle de la grande armée de l'empereur
j'ai fait partir par un aide de camp ce
matin des invitations pour certains
généraux afin d avoir à ma table pour
voir envisagé avec le le programme de
cet après midi leurs interventions
reconstitution d'instants militaires
mais aussi de vie de tous les jours
allez des métiers anciens et
démonstrations de danses d'époque de
quoi ravir les spectateurs
nous sommes ici dans le bivouac de
l'état-major mais vous avez également un
bivouac d officier de cavalerie à mes
voiles de l'infanterie vous avez des
artilleurs et ils tirent au canon à
blanc bien sûr vous avez des chevaux et
ont fait de la reconstitution de grandes
manoeuvres équestre bien sûr des revues
de trout le petit est passionné de
toutes les batailles napoléoniennes
notre objectif c'est d'aller à waterloo
dans quelques années pour justement voir
une des vraies batailles envoie l'époque
des gens du peuple
des artisans
des soldats du terrain comment ils
vivaient
les batailles de l'eau quand la vidéo
quotidien 400 reconstitueurs venus de
france et de belgique avaient fait le
déplacement des passionnés partageant
leurs connaissances clés tant que là que
vous voyez qui sont donc planché
revanche sont les tentes d'état-major du
prince murat
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]